I don't yet know the reasons why this is
happening but yesterday morning Fox News
daytime so not like the Tucker Carlson
Laura Ingraham Sean Hannity stuff the
daytime stuff that they claim is news
um seems to have been noticeably more
pro-vaccine now we're ultimately going
to come back to the reality about Fox
coverage about vaccines for months now
which is much like with the election was
stolen conspiracy theories they while
maybe not outright promoting
anti-vaccine sentiment were causing
anti-vaccine sentiment under the guise
of talking about freedom and by hosting
all sorts of so-called vaccine Skeptics
and anti-vaxx people so they've sort of
made the bed that they are now sleeping
in but yesterday I started seeing a
number of more
less overtly hostile to the vaccine's
videos could the explanation be the
rubber is meeting the road and Fox News
is actually starting to worry about
litigation because the Delta variant is
spreading it's increasingly clear that
this is overwhelmingly hitting
unvaccinated people I don't know what
the explanation is but let's take a look
at a couple of Clips here is an exchange
on Fox and Friends Brian Kilmeade
continues to be a very strong vaccine
hesitant voice although he admits in
this clip that he is vaccinated that's a
good thing but here he and Steve Doocy
sort of start mixing it up about
vaccination and the possibility that Max
masks are coming back on but listen if
you didn't get a vaccination that's your
choice and if you did like I did and and
they did so that's good it's good that
he's saying he got it it's good that
he's saying he got it even if he has all
the ifs ands and butts and maybe you did
then you should not wear a mask and if
you didn't if you want to go cliff
diving this weekend you don't have to
check with me it seems a little
dangerous but I'm not going to judge you
you and if you go ahead and put yourself
in danger if you feel as though this is
not something for you don't do it but
don't affect my life 99 of the people
who are dying from covid are
unvaccinated that's a fantastic
statistic to be putting out to this
audience and uh I am glad listen when
Steve ducey's the voice of reason you
know that everybody around you is making
no sense that's their choice they don't
want to die uh so they are the
administration and the government is
saying we need the mass mandate to
protect the unvaccinated that that is
not that's not their job it's not their
job to protect anybody so that is
absolutely fascinating for a couple of
different reasons first of all uh Brian
kilometer insists well Steve if it's
mostly the unvaccinated getting sick and
dying that's their choice and then Steve
Ducey says well they don't want to die
Steve Ducey has hit on something that's
really important to some degree and I
know some in the audience don't like
this perspective to some degree the
anti-vaxx people a lot of these
anti-vaxx Republicans are just victims
of disinformation and Steve Ducey is
right they don't want to die it's not
that they you know want to be martyred
making some kind of weird political
statement by not getting vaccinated and
then dying but the real Whopper here is
when kilmead says it's not the
government's job to protect anybody even
small government conservatives so-called
concede that they don't want the
government involved in almost anything
but where they do want the government
involved is to protect people now
stereotypically what they mean by that
is from foreign threats from foreign
militaries from bombs from terrorists
but a pandemic is a global and a
domestic threat it's not a foreign army
it's a virus apparently in Brian
kilmeade's mind that doesn't count or
that's a different story but they are by
encouraging vaccination the Biden
Administration is providing for the
common defense of the country of
Americans uh it would be you know is
kill me to okay with the FDA and food
inspection or is it listen it's People's
Choice to just hey you know that chicken
might be bad uh the the the Romaine or
the spinach it might have who knows what
we don't need FDA it's basically people
need to figure out their risk tolerance
no that's ridiculous and I've not heard
him come out against that although maybe
he would I don't know
um and lastly
although it's mostly the unvaccinated
it's not only the unvaccinated there are
people who are vaccinated and will still
get sick and there are people who can't
get vaccinated because of medical
conditions so the willingly unvaccinated
yes they mostly put themselves at risk
but they're also putting at risk other
people
immunocompromised and others also
complete blindness to their own
Network's role in fomenting this stuff I
mean have they seen Tucker's show have
they seen Laura Ingram show Etc that's
part of the reason that this is going on
but again here's another example here's
another daytime Fox clip from yesterday
where they seem to be very clearly
telling telling Their audience go and
get vaccinated I mean to them they're
going to feel like they're being
punished the unvaccinated should be
wearing masks in close quarters but that
could also be something that's
recommended rather than mandated this is
a propaganda Doctor Who who uh met with
Trump to go over Trump's cognition right
I mean this this is a full full-blown
Fox News propagandist but even he's
saying this stuff and I'm glad he is
quick question for you with this Delta
variant spreading across the country and
we see it's affecting the the stock
markets right now how important is it
for people to get vaccinated and where
can they get more information on where
to get a shot it's very important that
people get vaccinated because two shots
of Pfizer the modern vaccine is still
giving you almost 90 percent protection
against this and and 95 to 100
protection against hospitalization
hugely important you can get your
vaccine from a local pharmacy your
physician can tell you where to get it
they're they're really all over the
place very easy to get a vaccine right
now the public health centers all have
it there are vaccine centers still going
we're having a low compliance rate the
Delta variant needs to be a wake-up call
to get vaccinated so this is really
really good that they are doing that now
why are they doing it could be fear of a
lawsuit you heard them say oh the stock
market was down I'm I don't know why I
have this vision of you know so some uh
I don't even want to stereotype someone
who doesn't own any stocks and hasn't
wanted the vaccine hearing whoa whoa
whoa wait a second the stock market's
declining because of uncertainty now I'm
gonna go and get vaccinated as funny as
that would be I don't care what it takes
to get these people vaccinated and if
it's the stock market going down whether
or not not it affects them whether or
not they own a single fraction of a
share or whether it's a Fox News doctor
that Trump likes saying go and get
whatever it takes it's good that a
little bit during the day yesterday the
tide seem to be turning a little bit on
Fox News so that's a good thing we are
very close to the 16th anniversary of
the David Pacman show I know it's hard
to believe how could I have started a
show when I was only five years old it's
shocking to you it's shocking to my
parents it's shocking to everybody but
alas we are almost at our 16th
anniversary and in honor of that to
celebrate that we will be doing a one
day membership special at joinpakman.com
how can you not miss out just get on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com and then
Monday morning August 16th you'll get a
beautiful perfect email telling you
exactly how to Avail yourself of this
membership discount
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries from
the world's best filmmakers and right
now curiosity stream is giving you 25
off which comes out to just 14.99 a year
curiosity stream has a bigger selection
of documentaries than Netflix Hulu or
Amazon I'm always finding documentaries
on curiosity stream that I can't find
anywhere else and they always have the
newest and most critically acclaimed
titles I just finished watching autonomy
which is all about self-driving vehicles
and emerging technology that's going to
have a big impact on our economy on our
political system I can watch curiosity
stream on all of my devices they have
documentaries on politics economics
history technology psychology you name
it and when you go to
curiositystream.com Pacman my audience
will get 25 off that makes it 14.99 a
year not a lot of money for the amount
of enjoyment that I know you will get
from Curiosity stream and the link is
right underneath this video